Oh
I think of sex as a kaleidoscopic
expression of human desire right it's
the sum of all of our goals expressing
itself more as an aesthetic act than as
a kind of physical desire in some ways
to us to human beings sex is all mind
the body merely accompanies the
cognitive ecstasy to be attracted to
someone is to be attracted to a
narrative to be attracted to an idea to
be attracted to a scene to be attracted
to a moment she or he and the moment and
the music all of it a part of this dance
this aesthetic mental brain dance we
call human sexuality you know again this
kaleidoscopic multicolored sin aesthetic
expression of desire to want to
consummate right to lose oneself and one
another and experience this
intersubjective ecstasy this moment of
Revelation to become one with somebody
else
sexuality man again
human beings co-opting a biological
function and making it into an aesthetic
we are creatures of mind